you are attracted to helping women in
real big trouble like I remember the
story about you with Martha Stewart when
she was at her lowest she went to jail
you came out you defended her I think on
The View and you said listen if this was
a dude he wouldn't be going to jail
right she heard about it she asked you
to come to jail and visit her and like I
can point to about 10 women who have
been in trouble where you immediately
rushed to their side like in a big way I
mean you're a pretty busy person but yet
you do it what it's personal people that
I know I always reach out a hand you
know I didn't know Martha Stewart but I
wrote her an email before she left and
she had done my show a couple times but
right we had never had dinner I didn't
have a home phone number so I sent her
an email saying if you ever need
anything in prison please let me know
and two months later her assistant
called me and said would you please go
visit her and how weird was that well
you want to hear how silly I am I
thought it's prison I didn't take a
shower I had like a dirty you know like
I was trying to look as as low-key as I
could and I walk in there and she walks
through the door like she's in a scavulo
photo shoot her everywhere has Jolene
cream bleach that she told me she got at
the commissary she cinched her orange
jumpsuit and she cuffed her like she
looked fantastic and I looked like you
know her homeless cousin from Utah you
look like you were in prison exactly and
she and I said to her because you know I
didn't know her very well at all and I
said to her what do you miss the most
besides your daughter and your animals
obviously and she said the flavor of
lemon
and I said the flavor of lemon why
didn't you tell me it would have shoved
one up my hula come on I would have got
a lemon in here that would have been
nothing for me oh my God and so when she
came back from prison Howard you know
what I did I flew in a lemon tree from
Capri because it was in the winter and I
had it on her front porch for when she
came back and then I never heard from
her again how weird is it that you never
heard from her again I don't know I just
feel like I want to when I feel people
have suffered greatly I want to drop
Grace on them if I can
so I I feel like you know if you've your
whole life been suffering and things
were really bad and and you made a
mistake I I want to give you the
opportunity to recover